- What's up Believe Nation.
Today I'm going to share with
you my favorite top 10 rules
to success April 2017 edition.
And always guys, as people are talking,
if you hear something that
really resonates with you,
please leave it down
in the comments below,
put quotes around it as well
so other people can be inspired
and when you're writing something down,
it's much more likely to stick
with yourself as well, enjoy.
(wind blowing)
(basketball bouncing)
- The thing is, every
successful person you know
has failed at what they love to do before.
I've been unsuccessful in my career,
you just didn't know about it
'cause I wasn't famous yet,
I was trying to be famous, I
was trying to get a record deal
for six years and I kept
getting turned down.
And any successful person you know,
even though it seems like
everything just happened for them,
it usually was preceded
by a bunch of failure.
Or at least a significant amount,
but the great ones aren't
the ones that don't fail,
they're the ones that
learn from their failure
and they keep going and they're persistent
and their tenacious, and for me,
I was trying to get a
record deal from '98 to 2004
and I got turned down by
every major record label
including the one I'm signed to now,
and for me that means that
even when you hear "no,"
you have to keep going
through all those nos
until you get to yes.
- You know, I grew up in
Colombia, and Colombia
is a developing country
where a lot of people
don't have access to the most basic needs
and where education is considered
a luxury, unfortunately,
because we all know that
education is a birthright.
And I just grew up frustrated
seeing how many people
weren't able to realize
their own dreams, you know?
When I was eight years
old my dad underwent
an economic crisis, a financial crisis.
He lost his business and
we struggled economically
for many years.
We lost our car, we lost our furniture,
and I remember vividly the
day I walked in my house
and all the furniture was gone
because my dad had to pay his debts.
And it was quite shocking for me.
I was eight, seven, eight years old
and when I saw this I was so frustrated.
And so upset with my parents
because I couldn't understand
how they did so poorly in business.
I'm like, why, why?
I couldn't get it, and my dad and my mom
took me to the park where
they showed me other kids
my age sniffing glue, they were orphans,
they had no one to watch after them
and they were barefoot
and they were abandoned
to their own luck.
It probably left such an impression
in my impressionable mind at that age
that I remember that day and I remember
I made myself a promise, I said to myself,
"Shakira, you have to
succeed, because you have to
"ride in a car again one day.
"You have to get your own car someday."
And I wanted to vindicate my parents,
socially and economically,
and I also wanted to someday
do something for those kids
who I saw that day in the park,
so as soon as I had my first
big success with Pies Descalzos
which was my third album,
I decided to establish
my own foundation and do my
own contribution to the change,
even if it was going to be a small one,
but I wanted to be active and
that's how it all started.
Going through my own financial struggle
and the struggle of my
family and understanding
that the one thing that I never lacked
was care, protection, and an education,
and that's probably what
made me thrive in life.
- Don't wait, go, do it, act, now.
And really accepting we need
you, we need you, we need you.
You are the one percent,
you're the percent that says,
"I'm going to wake up,"
you're the lightworkers.
You're the ones that
have accepted this call
in this lifetime at this time
you have decided to wake up
and chosen to say, "Yes, I'm
here to be of greater service
"than just to feed myself," right?
I'm here to feed the world,
I'm here to give love,
I'm here to be an
expression of that truth.
Don't hold that back.
Don't play small.
We can't, we need you.
And so really, if you
are anyone in this room
who has been sitting on that book idea,
waiting a little bit longer
before you start that teacher training,
or doing 10 more teacher trainings
before you actually teach
if that's you, guys, start
and the pressure will be off.
I can't begin to tell you, I
could cry just saying this,
the day I taught Ego
Eradicator I was two weeks
into my teacher training and
I said, "F it, let's go!"
And I just went and I
felt so much pressure off.
I felt so much lift, because I just knew,
I felt this technology must be shared.
I can't hold it, I can't
keep it for myself.
I can't just sit in my
apartment by myself like this.
I got to give this.
(audience laughing)
And sharing it, the pressure
that was just lifted,
it was like, ah, thank you, thank you.
And I wasn't the perfect teacher,
and I looked back and I was
teaching Ego Eradicator wrong,
everyone's arms were like this,
everyone was breathing
backwards, it was a mess,
but I did it and I started,
and in those moments
when we just get to go, just go,
the pressure's off and
then we clear the path
and we are guided to the
next right action, and that
is the most magnificent
thing we could do right now.
- Your habits determine
what direction you're going.
Your success in life, your results in life
are in direct proportion to your habits.
Not what you say you're going to do,
but what are you going to do?
You've got to develop successful habits,
and I believe that starts
with being a daily goal setter
and a daily goal hitter,
that you get up, you know,
too many people spend
their whole life, they say
they're dreaming but they're
really just pipe dreams.
They're thinking about
what they want to be doing
in 20 years and what their plans are
way out in the future,
let me tell you what,
the future you need to be worried about
is not the next 20 years,
but the next 20 minutes.
What are you going to be doing?
What are you going to be
doing to be effective?
When you get up every
day, know your priorities.
Life will overwhelm you,
stuff will overwhelm you.
With all the information we have now,
whether it's your phone,
where sometimes I think
we have smart phones and stupid people.
I mean, it is so easy to get consumed
by a bunch of stuff that
is not going to get you
where you want to get to.
Say every day, "I will do
today what other's don't
"so I will have tomorrow
what other's won't."
You've got to choose to be effective.
Know what your priorities are.
Know what your must-dos are.
Don't let your phone,
don't let your tablet,
don't let the TV, don't let your friends
knock you off what are
the most important things
to get done today.
Sir Winston Churchill
didn't have an inbox,
he had an action this day box.
And so things didn't get into that box
that he wasn't going
to deal with that day.
As John Wooden said, "Make
today your masterpiece."
Get up today and get it
done, finish the day,
attack the day and go change your life.
- What you represent now,
for all those kids out there
trying to make it, whatever field it is,
whether it's music or something else,
what words do you have for them
in terms of how you've lived your life,
and you've made it to this point,
because you're not supposed
to be here right now.
- Nah, nah.
- What advice do you have for them
in terms of their lives and their journey?
- Lace up, lace up.
- What does lace up mean?
Say if it's the casual person
that might be seeing you for
the first time on this show,
what is lace up?
- It means what you want it to mean, but,
to me in a day and age like this,
it means put both feet
on that (bleep) ground,
(crowd cheering)
lace up,
get ready to face the world,
go out there, take it on
and turn a grain of sand into a diamond,
you know what I'm saying?
- Yeah.
(crowd cheering)
I think they love that
answer right there. (laughs)
They're definitely laced up.
- See, that's what it's about, man.
You know, it's about
believing in something,
you know what I'm saying?
Having faith in something,
man, that's what it is.
We're not trying to hear
some president in a suit
who can't even live his own life
because he's so worried
about public perception.
We can't relate to that,
you know what I'm saying?
They want to see someone
doing what they're doing,
living how they're living,
coming from where they're coming from
and making something better of themselves
than just sitting on their
ass, you know what I'm saying?
That's why they're screaming,
because they see that and
that's what I'm coming with
on this album, I'm just going
to be the people's champ.
- Yeah.
- You know what I mean?
I don't want to hear some reverend tell me
I have to believe in
an organized religion,
I don't want to hear
some president tell me
what he's going to do or not going to do
because they never do it.
I don't want to hear
some teacher put a limit
on where my education could take me,
you know what I'm saying?
They want to teach me to go
and fix lights in the house,
but they don't want to tell me
that I can take my own career
into my own hands and be an entrepreneur
and come up with something like this.
They didn't teach you
that you could do this.
I'm not scared, man, I'm ready to step up
and be a leader for this generation
and be a voice for this generation
and all these people can
act like they're talking
for these kids, but it's just an act.
I'm still one of those kids, man.
This means the world to me,
and that's what this album
is about and I just know things
are going to change, man.
I feel it, I believe
in like, I don't know.
- I think if you believe
in what you're doing,
many people will tell
you why you're mistaken,
why it'll never work, but if
you really believe passionately
what you're doing, and keep
pushing on, keep pushing on
until you either succeed
or at least you realize
that it's just not going to happen.
And then if you don't
succeed, pick yourself up
and try again and ultimately,
if you're that determined
you will succeed in life.
And if you don't you'll have
a hell of a lot of fun trying.
I'm most comfortable
when I'm in the studio.
And nothing else matters but the music.
You got to just love for it,
for something that you think
about, you sleep and you dream
and you wake up and you breath
it and you want to live it.
There's so many options,
there's many ways to blow up,
there's many ways to be
known and to get success
and to be successful,
and it's just about picking
that way that fits you.
- I kept going, I had a path,
I knew what my path was.
My path was to become what I am right now.
Now, I lost sight of it in
an interesting sort of way
or I went about it in a wayward path,
but fortunately for me,
all the gettin' high,
the drinkin', the drugs,
everything else I did,
I showed up at the theater every day.
- Right.
- I did plays
ripped out of my mind, I
rehearsed ripped out of my mind,
but every lesson that I learned,
I held onto for some reason
God, whatever, somebody let me hold on
to everything that I was learning.
My stage lefts and my stage rights,
my upstage foot always
out, turn down this way,
learning how to develop a
character, doing all those things,
because those were the things that I loved
and I did them in the
midst of everything else
that I was doing to when my friends
were getting ready to go
get some more drugs, I'd go,
"Oh, no, I got to be at the theater,
"I'll catch you all when the
theater's over," when I'm done.
And I'd get, or I got to go
build a set, I got to do this.
So I did everything that I had to do,
so I was focused on this
by any means necessary.
Plus I had a professor who was like,
"Well, you know, all the
great ones do their jobs
"and get ripped out of their minds.
"You know, you look at the
Peter O'Tooles and the,
"they get drunk and they get
high, they do what they do,
"but they show up and they do the job."
So we were like, "OK,"
and that's what we did.
You know, we drank with him and we went
to styles of acting class,
we'd go smoke a joint
and come in and do our
other acting classes
or go build a set or build some costumes
or hang some lights and
do all of the things
that we had to do,
so I kept learning my
lessons and doin' 'em.
- Sometimes a lot of people
may try a new initiative
and then they don't get
an immediate reaction
and they think it's a failure.
- [Gary] That's right.
- I want to go back to your YouTube videos
with the Wine Library, you
had so much content out there.
How did you stick in there,
how did you keep yourself motivated?
- Because I believe in my strategies
and I'm patient as, like, all great stuff,
especially when you're innovating
doesn't happen right away.
This notion that like,
"Oh Gary, I tried it,
"I spent 500 bucks on Facebook
ads, it doesn't work."
Well what if your videos sucked,
what if your product and service sucks?
I tend to do things that are very early,
that has been my career.
When I do things I believe in them.
I stick with them based on intuition,
even though for 18 months
nobody watched my wine videos
at all, I knew it was right, I was right,
there's been things I've
done that I jumped off of
very quickly, I started a
Gary V app, VeeChat, V E E,
like WeChat, I thought
it was funny for my fans,
great CRM one-on-one, didn't
feel right after a week or two
spent plenty of money building it,
stopped it after couple months.
Wine Library TV, five
years, every day YouTube,
decided to change it to
Daily Grape, insular app,
you could buy stuff,
subscription for reviews,
it was a lot of fun, only
did it for five months,
stopped it 'cause it
didn't feel right anymore.
It's always hard to know when
to jump off something new,
but I find that people don't
believe in what they're doing.
They hear a guru and
they do it begrudgingly
'cause their boss wants
them to or they're like,
well, Gary's right a lot, so let me do it,
but they don't believe
it and so then they jump.
They're looking for nos instead of yesses.
Everything I do, every
business development,
every event I do, every time
I try a new marketing tactic
or a sales tactic I'm looking for the yes.
- Right.
- I'm looking for the yes,
and if the no punches me,
well then I'm like,
crap, the no punched me.
I believe the majority of
people when they try new tactics
are looking for the no, and
you're going to be getting
a lot of subtle nos immediately.
- [Interviewer] Right.
- And so I think that's why that happens.
- Your success has been
dramatic, obviously,
and coming from a city
like Chennai, of course,
culturally very rich, we are
in our own state of Tamil Nadu,
but more importantly, to be
able to go global with that
has been just quite
awe-inspiring to be honest
and made all of us so
proud here in Chennai,
but if you look at young musicians today
and what they are being offered,
and the technology, it's
moved along as well,
what would you say to them?
- I think they have to
find their own voice.
They find their own inner voice.
The moment we try to do somebody else's,
we become mediocre.
The moment we try, our limitations
are sometimes are plusses
so sometimes that forces
you to think in a way where,
there are many millions
of ways to achieve a song,
or achieve greatness in art,
so you find a different way.
You know, a classic
example is Kumar Gandharva,
a classical singer, he had a lung problem
or something so he
couldn't sustain his notes.
If you listen to his rendering,
he would just make everything short.
(singing with abrupt end)
He wouldn't like, (sings drawn-out note)
he would never sustain it
because of his breathing problem.
But that became a great style.
You don't have to copy
that because his limitation
became a style of what
he could amazingly do
and it was unique when he sang.
And so I think all of us have limitations
and we should not think it's a limitation.
So there's something else which is there,
a plus within you and then bring that out
and then you become totally different.
- You weren't created by a mediocre God.
You weren't created to be mediocre,
you were created for good works
which He planned beforehand.
You were created to do amazing things,
and sometimes we just got
to realize our potential.
We got to realize it, we were
created by an awesome God,
we were created to do amazing things,
and if sometimes we
just have the confidence
that we were created to
do something special,
then go do something special,
but you have to believe in yourself.
You have to believe that you are gifted
for such a time as this,
you have to believe
that you have the talent,
that you can make the
choice every single day
to wake up, to love it,
to be passionate about it
and sacrifice.
- Thank you guys so much for watching.
I'd love to know, what did you think?
What was your favorite clip?
What are you going to take from this video
and immediately apply to your
life or your business somehow?
Leave it down in the comments below.
I'm super curious to find
out, so thank you guys again
for watching, I believe in you,
I hope you continue to
believe in yourself,
and whatever your one word is,
much love, I'll see you soon.
(wind howling)
(basketball bouncing)